hey roku where's my remote
game changer tv sets have gotten bigger
thinner and smarter through the years
meanwhile these things have been slow to
keep up but that's finally changing
manufacturers are shipping tvs and
streaming sticks with updated remotes
yes people still care about remotes even
though you can yell at your smartphone
to control your tv let me explain how
these next generation remotes plan on
solving all of your media consumption
woes but first why now because we grew
accustomed to barking out orders at all
our smart devices physical remotes fell
out of favor or so companies thought the
biggest news here is the addition of a
remote when google first launched the
chromecast in 2013
the device shipped without a remote and
largely dependent on your smartphone
that continued until 2020 then google
changed its strategy according to katie
morganroth google's industrial design
manager a physical remote allows you to
step away from the notifications
distractions and potential stresses that
you may find there in other words they
found that consumers didn't want to
replace the good old clicker remotes
also evolved as many of us changed from
clicking through cable channels to
streaming more content online so now
you'll see more shortcuts on your remote
to launch streaming apps
also tv and streaming device companies
have had time to experiment and figure
out how to do more with smaller remotes
all without creating extra buttons that
just confuse new users now for the fun
stuff the latest and greatest in remote
technology at ces in january samsung
showed us this a self-charging remote
that lets you stop burning through
batteries it sips on radio waves from
your wi-fi router for power it's also
solar powered so you can charge it with
your indoor lights you can charge it
with the sun or if you're on a train
want to launch netflix or search for
movies on roku while your hands are full
roku launched voice remote pro
the controller has a tiny speaker and
microphone built into it and it's always
listening out for your hey roku commands
sony's new remote comes with a remote
finder feature that makes the clicker
ring out loud apple's second try at a
streaming remote is also a winner the
latest siri remote fixes the touch pad
and size issues that people had with the
first generation instead of a wide touch
surface it has a touch enabled button
that's a bit easier to control and it's
thicker so it's less likely to get lost
and there's one more amazon's new fire
tv omni series screens have so much
alexa functionality that you probably
don't even need a remote just ask the tv
questions the same way you would ask
your smart speaker all of these features
are great to have but there's no one
remote that has all of them so i tested
out several of them to find out how easy
they were to use how hard they were to
lose and how effortless they were to
juice let's be honest no one's gonna buy
a new tv just for the remote so for the
sake of this comparison we can eliminate
sony and samsung that leaves us with the
newest remotes from apple roku and
google all three of these options are
solid if you want a media player but
many of us have nice looking tvs that
suffer from out-of-date interfaces so it
could be smart to get an affordable
upgrade after some extensive research
testing and talking to the companies
about what each of these can do i have a
recommendation for you if you're making
your decision based on user interface
and remote features go with roku the
company's streaming stick 4k plus comes
with two programmable buttons and you
can use them to create shortcuts to your
favorite apps or your favorite tv shows
and with voice remote pro you can talk
to it it's even rechargeable but it's
the find my remote feature for me that
sealed the deal
i don't like that chromecast remotes
require aaa batteries and apple has
technology to find missing laptops
iphones and airpods so why can't i use
that to find the new siri remote look
people just want to watch tv and remotes
should make that easier not more
difficult and that means not getting
lost in the cushions and or running out
of battery maybe that's just me
what feature do you wish your remote had
let me know in the comments and make
sure to subscribe to learn more about
the latest tech and where it's all
headed we'll chat soon